meet the relatives these are our closest
cousins the great apes we like to think
we're different but a few million years
ago we were just the same now we
dominate the planet somehow we humans
have left apes far behind or have with
through a series of experiments will
prove that apes are much closer to us
than anyone thought startling images
reveal that their instant memory is far
superior to ours
apes can understand hundreds of words
they have a form of language and they
use more complex tools than anyone
realized by looking at the differences
and similarities between Apes and us we
may find the secret ingredient that
makes Apes Apes and humans human we take
it for granted but self recognition is a
fundamental building block of human
society we exist as individuals each
with our own unique features
scientists believe self recognition is
essential for our survival we can live
in large groups because we recognize
similar features to our own in others we
can tell friend from foe
that is self recognition uniquely human
show a monkey a mirror and it thinks
it's another monkey it attacks but how
will our closer relatives the great apes
react when faced with their own image
this three-year-old chimpanzee has never
seen a mirror before he's not sure what
to make of it
erect fur is usually a sign of fear or
anger but his fear is soon replaced by
curiosity
when chips see themselves in years the
first time they naturally assume it's
another chimp the way a human being
who's never seen themselves aboard does
and begin to play with mirror image soon
this chimp will know it's looking at
itself just like these older chimps they
know exactly what mirrors do
this chimp appears to know that that's
her tongue and those are her teeth
chimpanzees seem to have a concept of
the bodily self that allows them to look
into a mirror and say that image is
equivalent to this body but how can we
prove that humans and chimpanzees really
identify the figure in the mirror as
themselves psychologists have a
well-known test for this it's called the
mark test a researcher marks a child's
cheek the child then looks in a mirror
he moves his hand up to the mark
he recognizes himself by the age of two
half of all children tested can
recognize themselves soon they all do so
can our ape cousins pass this test a
keeper places a mark on a female
orangutan next they put her in front of
a mirror she had seen her reflection
before but this time she notices that
something has changed her hand goes to
the mark
all the great apes gorillas orangutans
chimps and bonobos can pass the mark
test by a certain age